so as we continue our story on the age
of Ultron I'm very excited to bring you
guys issue number seven and the reason
why is because this is going to give us
a really cool depiction of what the
world is like without Hank Pym now for
the most part we actually haven't really
seen a world like this before we've seen
versions of it we've seen variants of
what it would be like without a
character for example with Charles
Xavier having being killed by Legion we
saw the Age of Apocalypse and with the
house of M we saw The Scarlet Witch
warping reality but what we're going to
see for the most part is a very dark in
a very dystopian future and it's really
not like anything that we've seen to
this point because we're going to see
some very interesting depictions of
characters that we are quite familiar
with but as we continue with this story
we see that of course Susan storm and
Wolverine are headed back to dr. Doom's
time platform and of course again
they're going to be using this platform
to travel from the past back to the
present and for the most part the Susan
storm is very curious about what's
taking place she's very unsure of things
for her she feels as though they've
crossed some line that they can't come
back from and Wolverine tells her that
she was told to wait in the car but the
fact that she chose to up here when
Wolverine was getting ready to kill Hank
Pym and the fact that she didn't stop
will rain from killing Hank Pym means
that as far as Wolverine is concerned
she's just as guilty as he is at this
point we transitioned back to the
present where Wolverine and Susan storm
have arrived and what we see taking
place is that the Savage Land is much
different than they had previously seen
where in the normal timeline when Ultron
had taken over the present they had left
the Savage Land which had a litany of
potholes and markers to indicate that a
conflict had taken place there we see
that now the Savage Land appears to be
some massive area housing a series of
different kinds of ships then again
Susan storm and and Wolverine aren't
sure what to make of this they really
don't know what to do about this and so
Susan storm makes both Wolverine and
herself invisible and they transition
down or I guess they move down to the to
the ground level to investigate what's
going on what we also see is that there
appear to be various individuals who are
perhaps digging or the very least maybe
trying to read
however some some various forms of
relics but we also see there are a
couple guards down here now the guards
refer to themselves as start guard
security indicating that perhaps
whatever it is that they're doing here
is done at the behest of Tony Stark but
we also get a little bit of explanation
here at the very least what passes for
explanation and Susan storms hypothesis
and Susan storm believes that because of
the fact that they've discovered a skull
belonging to one of the scrolls because
of the fact that some of these ships are
of scroll origin and Kree origin that
perhaps the kree-skrull war did not go
the way that it had in the normal Marvel
timeline and what I mean by this is of
course the Korean the scroll had been
warring for quite some time and the
planet Earth was a strategic location it
was really a major point within the
conflict between the Kree in the scroll
but during the more what the normal
timeline the Avengers had helped to
stave off the conflict from coming to
the planet Earth and this is one of the
reasons why Wolverine is unaware of the
crease World War but it appears as
though in this timeline where Hank Pym
doesn't exist that the crease World War
was not stopped or at the very least it
was not kept from coming to the planet
Earth and so from here we see that again
Susan storm and and Wolverine are not
necessarily panicking here but at the
very least are trying to figure out
what's going on and so they take Nick
Fury's I guess hover car and they travel
back to New York City but once they
arrive to New York they see that the
city isn't necessarily totally destroyed
but at the very least it's a shadow of
its former self in the sense that a lot
of the buildings appear to have Saints
attained some kind of damage or at the
very least they're simply beginning to
rot away or beginning to fall apart into
a state of decay what they also see is a
multitude of shield helicarriers that
are maybe observing the city or the very
least probably trying to keep the city
safe again we don't really know here but
Susan storm questions that she asked the
question what is it that they've done
what is it that's happened here as a
result of a hank pym being killed off
before they can investigate to much
further their hover car is shot down at
this point we of course again see them
trying to figure out what's going on
trying to understand what's taken place
and will reign as he
ask Susan storm what it is that shot
them down or perhaps where it came from
Susan storm replies by saying that that
she doesn't know that she has no idea
where that shot came from but before
again they can investigate too much
further a voice seems to chime in and
ask him what it is they think that
they're doing here at this point it's
revealed to us that the Avengers
apparently don't exist anymore and that
in place of the Avengers we now have the
defenders and the defenders again was a
group that was largely formed under dr.
strange in the normal Marvel Universe
but the group was not necessarily on the
same level as the Avengers but it seems
that it in this reality that it is what
we also see is a change in line up from
the defenders wear during the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline we saw the defenders
composed of Doctor Strange The
Incredible Hulk Namor the Submariner and
others instead we have what appears to
be Captain America with an eyepatch as
well as Peter quill Jan Van Dyne who's
wearing Miss Marvel's uniform the
Incredible Hulk
of one-eyed Cyclops and the alternate
reality version of Wolverine now what
we're going to be doing for the sake of
this discussion is we're going to be
referring to the alternate reality
version of Wolverine as just that as the
alternate reality version of himself but
in order to differentiate between him
and the other version of will reign
we're going to refer to the one from the
normal timeline as a normal wolf rain
just as just so that we can keep things
easy to understand without things
getting too convoluted but we also see
and what's really interesting here is
that the thing is part of the defenders
but the thing is very surprised to see
Susan storm because for some reason she
may not exist in this timeline or at the
very least may have simply just vanished
from here because of the fact that they
don't really know what's going on that
they assume that the normal version of
Wolverine and Susan storm are Scrolls
and so the intention of the defenders is
to capture them now initially the idea
of the Incredible Hulk is to pummel them
to absolutely smash them but Doctor
Strange tells The Incredible Hulk to
hold on and of course Captain America
tells everybody to start talking he
tells the normal version of Wolverine
and Susan storm to explain but again for
the most part what's also I guess
intriguing and this is something that we
haven't necessarily touched on
is that Jan Van Dyne chimes in and says
that perhaps this is some sort of trick
at the hands of Morgana lafay now we
haven't talked about Morgana LeFay and
Marvel Comics and the reason why is
because for the most part she's an
adversary of Spider Woman Doctor Doom
and various other people but she's not a
very very big character she's not one
that gets top billing but because of the
fact that she is a major player in this
story it really changes things
it is really Marvel more or less taken
Morgana lafay and elevating her to a
mainstream character in addition we see
that of course the thing says that he
hasn't seen Susan storm in years and
this is going to be a major part of Ben
Grimm as he is trying to figure out
what's going on and operating as part of
the defenders in the sense that for
whatever reason for whatever it is this
happened here Susan storm again doesn't
exist in this timeline and so from here
we see the Susan storm using her
abilities blast the defenders off guard
and when she does in the time that
they're occupied she grabs a Wolverine
and makes the both of them invisible
now from here Wolverine the normal
version of Wolverine and Susan storm try
to escape but as the normal version of
Wolverine explains it this isn't going
to do them any real good and the reason
why is because the alternate reality
version of Wolverine is most likely like
the normal version and if that's the
case then when Wolverine picks up a
scent he never loses it and so it's
going to be highly unlikely that the
normal version of Wolverine and Susan
storm are going to be able to
successfully get away from the alternate
reality version of Wolverine and the
defenders and of course this is what we
see we see that almost immediately after
they get away that they're pursued and
tracked down by the defenders and what
we see is this conflict taking place we
see this really interesting kind of
situation where Susan storm and the
normal version of Wolverine are doing
the best they can to hold off the
defenders but in the end they're
unsuccessful they're not actually able
to get away and so for the most part
they're taken away they're held captive
by the defenders and taken back to
presumably maybe one of the the shield
helicarrier's or perhaps even the the
main shield base but what's also very
interesting is we get some in-depth I
may be
insight into the defenders in the sense
that they again don't really know what's
going on here now initially the idea is
they're saying they don't want to talk
to him
whoever Hamm is but of course Doctor
Strange says that most likely they're
going to need to they're going to have
to talk to him and what we learn is that
the hem they're referring to is actually
Tony Stark and that this version of Tony
Stark differs vastly to the normal
version of Tony Stark in the sense that
this one appears to be some amalgamation
of cybernetics and normal humanoid
appearances indicating that perhaps he's
a robot
or perhaps he's simply some kind of
cyborg with that being said we're going
to go ahead and bring this video to an
end I hope you guys enjoyed it if you
did let me know and I will catch you
guys later peace
you